Trascrizione: Emilia Panzarino
Revisore: Helena Caruso
Ciao. Visto che dobbiamo parlare di
fuoco, allora si può associare
l’elemento alla passione.
E quindi vi faccio sentire questa canzone.
Che per me in qualche modo
rappresenta il fuoco.
Sulle tue curve la mia mano ondeggerà
Anche se il tuo corpo
Di curve
Non ne ha.
Sei sempre più spigoloso
Poi sorridi se mi mostro geloso
Amami uomo
Con le mani
Da uomo
E toccami fiero
Con un soffio
Leggero
Bello di mammà
Tosto macho per papà
L’uomo senza curve un donnone sposerà
No! C’è anche amore senza rima
Voglio urlare più forte di prima
Amami
Uomo
Con le mani
Da uomo
E toccami fiero
Con un soffio
Leggero
E portami via
Delle braccia tue sarò in balia
Prendimi, apparecchiami poi sorprendimi
Con un mazzo di fiori freschissimi
Tranquillizzati
Ora vado lì a cantare
Che io me ne vo
Un postino diventerò
E non c’è pericolo per il ciao mammà,
ciao papà
L’uomo senza curve
Un altro uomo abbraccerà
Sarà la sua felicità
Amami uomo
Con le mani
Da uomo
E toccami fiero
Con un soffio leggero
Questa era “Il Postino”.
Se penso al fuoco e, di conseguenza,
all’elemento
e dunque alla passione,
un’altra cosa
che è molto forte, viva e che mi sa di
rosso appena la ascolto
è questa qui.
Non è mia.
Amarti m’affatica
Mi svuota dentro
Qualcosa che assomiglia
a ridere nel pianto
Amarti m’affatica
Mi dà malinconia
Che vuoi farci, è la vita
E la vita è la mia
Amami ancora
Fallo dolcemente
Solo per un’ora, perdutamente
Amami ancora
Fallo dolcemente
Solo per un’ora
Perdutamente
Grazie.